you know those anime chicks that you
don't actually think exist in real life
you know like young girls who like anime
and actually watch it and are incredibly
hot a couple of them sat next to me in
the theater during this movie Trigon is
a really famous anime that debuted in
1998 and it got a really good following
when it came over to America on the
Adult Swim Network right around the same
time that Cowboy Bebop started getting
popular on the same network and there's
a lot of similarities to come a bebop as
well it's very much a Western but it has
a lot of science fiction elements to it
as well just like Cowboy Bebop anime
fans owe a lot to Cartoon Network it
introduced us to Dragon Ball Z Cowboy
Bebop
Sailor Moon yes I know Sailor Moon but
hey sailor moons are classics oh shut up
I lost our Gundam Wing rurouni kenshin a
lot of really great shows came over from
Japan to Adult Swim in the Cartoon
Network and I became a huge fan of
Trigon I watched the entire series and I
even read a little bit of the manga and
I can say that I'm an anime fan but I
will watch everything I love Hymas Aki's
films Dragon Ball Z and cowboy bebop in
Trigon I also really love most a death
note until later in the series usually
when an anime film is made that's based
off of a TV series it's never as good as
the show and the creator's almost always
make it because the show is suddenly
really famous so hey we got to make some
more and so a lot of times it's not that
great not the case here
if you're gonna keep getting in my way
[Music]
trigons about a character named Vash and
he's more well known by what everyone
else knows him by Vash the Stampede
he has a sixty billion double dollar
bounty on his head which is a term they
use in this world and he's known as the
most dangerous man alive but it's
interesting because he's never actually
killed a person in his life he's taken a
vow to never kill someone he's just
always in the wrong place at the wrong
time he'll be in the middle of a bank
robbery or something and everyone gets
killed and everyone just assumes it's
him you know some giant explosion will
happen he happens to be nearby and they
just assume it's him and so he's gotten
this reputation for being this horrible
killer and everyone's afraid of him but
he's actually an incredibly innocent
childlike person who is hilarious I'm
the one who threw the die on this one
just goes out there and kills more
people April like my mother this
villainous man is supposedly going
towards this city where Bash is because
he has a grudge against some people
there Bosch meets this girl who has a
grudge against the villain and everyone
is intertwined in this huge story that
involves something that happened 20
years ago eventually it all leads to a
big climactic confrontation which was
really riveting and this is one of the
better anime movies I've ever seen
actually it's because the creators of
the show did the character and did the
entire story of Trigon justice one of
the things about anime movies is a lot
of times they're made because wow
somebody just realized hey this show we
made is really popular
we should make old movies too there
hasn't been an original trigon animation
in over 10 years and that's because the
Creator is we're just gonna sell out and
make some movie just based on trigons
popularity so I really really respect
that
this film looks beautiful the animation
is fantastic it has such a cool Western
atmosphere I love the combination of
sci-fi and Western that's when Cowboys
and Aliens had this year that I really
really dug how we do up and try gonna
have it as well and there are two my
favorite animates the villain in this
film is really well realized he's not
just some faceless evil guy he has a
plan he has an agenda he has a reason
for doing what he's doing and you
understand why he's doing it
same goes for the supporting characters
the girl the batchmates wolfwood comes
back if you know about Trigon you
recognize that name the character is a
million merrill are back and they're
still really funny all the characters in
this film have a really good motivation
for why they're there they're not just
there because oh they're from the show
or whatever film has such a wonderful
sense of humor and really well animated
action I really enjoy Trigon it's
definitely a really good anime film you
think the guy who just talked about
turned out to be a mother
[Music]
and here's really my only flaw with the
film and it's not so much a flaw that I
have but it's a flaw that you might have
if you're not a fan of anime you'll
definitely not enjoy this film as much
as I did if you're not a fan of Trigun
there are definitely things you won't
understand in this film as well it's
because it's one of those movies that
you kind of have to have seen the show
or at least understand parts of it so
really if you haven't seen the show of
try again you probably shouldn't see the
movie so I would give Trigon an A -
because I like anime I like Trigon and
this is an incredibly well-made anime
film that pleases the fans and
definitely has them in mind however if
you are not an anime fan and you just
appreciate this kind of animation or if
you're not even into that animation I
would lower that grade considerably I
however am and loved dragons so I would
give it a very high grade it's a very
very well made anime I don't want you to
jump in
always trying to still respond
[Music]
so I am going to have more anime reviews
coming your way I've already done one
for Dragonball Z I'm planning on doing
one for Cowboy Bebop and you can look
forward to that until next time you can
subscribe to my channel and get stopping
eyes
[Music]